what's keeping up with the kardashians  filming at the time Kim was robbed an  east oaks person tells ET in a statement  all of us at E are incredibly thankful  that Kim kardashian-west is safe and we  send her and her family our love and  support keeping up with the kardashians  was not filming at the time of the  robbery our focus right now is entirely  on Kim's well-being Kim is now safely  back on US soil after being held at  gunpoint tied up and robbed at her  apartment in Paris on Sunday last night  he abruptly stopped his live performance  in Queens when news broke his wife was  robbed I'm sorry family emergency I have  to stop shop  a rep for Kim previously told et she was  confronted by two armed masked men who  posed as police officers quote she is  badly shaken but physically unharmed